hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on Borderlands 3 again
and today is gonna be the final episode
of the crew challenges videos if you
want to see the other two which has to
do with torque and then the mayor you
can check the end of this video it don't
all be at the links at the very end of
the video but today is the last one and
we're gonna be tackling ember and of
course we have to go find the statues
and we have to go blow them up with the
fire and stuff like that so there's like
five or so locations that we have to go
to and at the end she will give us a new
legendary weapon very similar to how
Torg did i'm only gonna be showing a
little bit of the weapon not a full
in-depth guide there's probably videos
out there for you if you really want to
do that and also do be where any
controller players like I stated in my
last video if you have stick drift on
your controller I'm not saying this is
impossible but it is very [ __ ] hard
on some of these other sections of the
map which you'll see they will be a big
struggle if your controller has stick
drift so be on the lookout for that but
it's always like the V if we do enjoy
subscribe if you're new there will be
timestamps in the description if you're
missing one of the sections and with
that peace out let me know just think
about the weapon and enjoy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]